we can yeah yeah the coronavirus yeah
what do you think about what's going on
to come up karna virus well I don't know
I it's it's both scary and also I I
don't know what to believe because I you
know there's all these different stories
going on but you know but the fatalities
all old people for the most part for the
most part so it's like but you know
healthy yeah you know I was reading that
like the mortality rate for SARS mm-hmm
was like near 10% okay yeah that's
that's that's crazy you know I mean and
the mortality rate for this reported so
far is like 2% okay maybe three maybe
four yeah but the scary thing is that
they're lying like well so a study came
out that said I think we talked about
this of the day that based on the time
at which people had become infected okay
it had to have started earlier than
China actually said and so you know
China's denying it and they're now
saying no no no people got sick from you
know this meat market and then and now
it's like you know I don't look man you
know a lot of people are a lot you know
upset why don't you do more research
into this dude listen everybody's got
some insane conflicting information it's
hard to know what's really happening you
know there was the bat soup thing you
know BuzzFeed's like fake news but i'm
why am i bust feet on this one you know
i mean like they know yeah what do they
do they did the same google search I did
and read Daily Mail or BBC or something
right but you know I think when you look
at how they're rapidly expanding these
hospitals seems like they're really
worried about something man
yeah I don't know if that's why I think
the more telegrams got to be higher cuz
maybe I'm wrong too young but I don't
remember like this mass mobilization
during SARS you know no that's true but
maybe maybe I was like I was I think I
was what like seventeen sixteen
seventeen when SARS happens like 2005 or
2003 2003 so I was like even 15 or 16 or
something yeah yeah so maybe I just
didn't pay times you don't think it's
just the government trying to get a hold
of this thing get ahead of it because
they're just being more proactive now
than they were maybe her stars but I
don't trust China you know I mean look
at your Nobel yeah let's read this story
this is one of the latest stories we
have my family is in lockdown in wuhan
Wisconsin father begged us State
Department to let his wife his
five-year-old daughter and his 10 month
old baby leave on the only evacuation
flight out of the coronavirus stricken
city I just want to say right now I mean
kind of sounds like a bad idea
like there's a quarantine for a reason
should we probably do we do we tell
American sounds really bad for those two
kids it's terribly man you're
quarantined dude it's true it's like
you're in ground zero and you have like
the most you know susceptible people
people which are babies you know yeah no
I mean I feel bad from but they they
could probably at least be checked
can't they you know not a week
incubation period yes it seems crazy to
me that we're talking about bringing
people there was there was a one-story I
saw of someone like from New Zealand
yeah it's like trying to hop like
begging the US and like other country
it's like get me out of here
yeah like streets are all deserted and
everything I don't know man I kind of
feel like you should probably stay is
that callous that mean no I mean it's
quarantine bro this does turn out to be
something that's you know fatal then
they should stay you know it reminds me
of like you ever see those movies where
they always break quarantine yeah I
can't stand it I can't was that movie
with like like I think Ryan Reynolds is
in it or something and it's called life
and it's like I can't remember but I
think it's like Aegis Elba he like puts
his hand in that glove and like there's
like a life form then it like breaks his
hand or something maybe there was a
different character and they're like we
got to get him out and they're like no
he's quarantine I don't care and then
they open the door anyway and it's like
the whole movie is based on you
violating the protocol yeah I'm supposed
to violate that's a premise whole or a
plot hole in so many movies like that
too why do they do this there's always
that one person you know man I don't
care about this quarantine open the door
I can't stand movies you know you know I
can't say movies were that where the
plot is based on character stupidity
yeah it's like great I can't stand it
why couldn't they make it like the alien
broke the quarantine yeah they were like
we did the right thing we had no choice
in this man
that it's always like you know but but I
gotta be honest yeah maybe if it's
realistic like you have this story where
people are trying to get out of the
quarantine in the u.s. is actually
evacuating people cuz they don't believe
they have it they're like I'm clear I'm
no they don't care I don't think they
care I think you know the concern of
people is me that's true it's like I
gotta get out you know I mean you know
let's read a little bit more of this
story because you know I wanted to read
this one because it feels a bit it's a
good it's a it's a good story to focus
on this individual right he's he's a
human being he's got a family man he's
got kids yeah we want to save this
family they're Americans definitely but
man's a tough call right it definitely
is if coronavirus kills one person in
America and it comes from him mm-hmm
then we then was it worth you know
saving the guy let me read they say this
Wisconsin feather father feather all
Wisconsin father begged the State
Department to evacuate his wife and two
daughters one of whom is an infant who
are trapped in the lockdown city of
Wuhan amid the corona virus outbreak
Samuel Roth took to Twitter Monday
pleading my family is currently in
lockdown in Wuhan when will my wife and
two daughters one of whom was only 10
months old be offered seats on the
chartered flight Sam's wife Daisy and
daughters Adeline and Abigail flew to
China last week to spend Lunar New Year
with Daisy's family in Wuhan shortly
after their after the city was put in
lockdown
leaving the Roth family stranded and now
Sam's plea with the State Department has
been turned down the last flight out of
Wuhan left Tuesday and Daisy and Edelin
and Abigail weren't in any of its 240
seats now quote there's no telling when
they will be able to get us out Sam
wrote on Facebook well I'll tell you
what man I feel for you Sam I really do
you know I don't want anybody be hurt
and we put in put in danger but bro
you're in a quarantine city man yeah
there is a disease I know the mortality
rate is projected to be relatively low
right now but if we pull people out of
this and then it spreads and hits
thousands of people in the US and there
are deaths it's like that could have
been averted you know yeah so I think
them agree I think for the most part
they say that's really the gist of the
story we'll read a little bit more here
they say when the public transportation
within Wuhan and flights ferries trains
and roads and out in and out of the city
were shut down on January 23rd some
1,000 Americans were trapped along with
the city's 11 million Chinese residents
I mean yeah that's how quarantine work
yeah each day they stayed the number of
people infected climbed by minute on
Friday 830 people were sick with the
SARS like coronavirus that seemed to
have emerged an open-air seafood market
in the wound in the Wuhan I think they
made a mistake where a live game and
exotic fish and animals were sold now
the number of cases has surged well past
4000 more than 100 people have died of
the newly discovered respiratory
infection and most of them were in Wuhan
Gabriel lung of the University of Hong
Kong said draconian travel measures are
necessary to stop the spread of the
virus few passengers are expected are
expected to still be trickling into the
u.s. from Wuhan and the airports in the
city are now closed meaning travel to
and from the city is nearly impossible
for u.s. citizens Monday the Centers for
Disease Control Prevention CDC issued a
level-3 travel advisory recommending
that all non-essential travel to any
part of China be avoided only travel to
Wu Hans Hubei Province was met with the
travel agency's highest level for
advisory with officials urging Americans
not to travel there at all I mean you
can't so yeah but thanks for the
advisory the exception of the State
Department's chartered flight set to
leave Wuhan as far as we know it's the
last flight out of the city at the
center of the outbreak a US official
with knowledge of the matter told CNN
that the plane is a Boeing 767 a plane
that seats 240 people less than a
quarter of the Americans currently
trapped in Wuhan and so we can see
pictures of the family and they say it's
primarily being sent to evacuate
employees of the government diplomats
and US officials but some seats are to
be open to private citizens Sam's family
faces tough odds getting on the flight
which is supposed to land somewhere in
California all right you know a man III
kind of got mad about that
what about woodwork of course they're
gonna evacuate the people who work for
the government yeah you know I can I can
respect to a certain degree yes they
prioritize that mmm but it kind of just
reminds me of how like you know they
want to ban guns except for themselves
you know I mean you see politicians walk
around saying we go to have good in
control I'm actually gonna pull a Bernie
like go in control you know and then you
see he's got a bunch of armed guards
yeah it's like if you if I get it
government resources are gonna pull
people out because they work for the
government fine I get it but I'm kind of
like you know I mean
but I think none of them should come out
that's kind of the issue I agree yeah
man
for reasons I already stated if this
becomes something substantially worse so
what's that
what does that matter not your if you're
in a quarantine zone you should stay
there too until you're checked and made
sure you're good to me yeah I mean have
you seen that movie quarantine I have
yeah what if there's zombies oh you know
it's scarier than like zombie movies
they don't they don't get it you know
scarier is contagion like yeah I would
be less scared of a mindless zombie like
milling about yeah that I can just be
like I don't care you can see that
though but what if it's a person begging
you covered in like their eyes are
bleeding and you can tell they're
infected and they're coming towards you
frantically shaking like help me please
and you're like you know wait and then
you got to choose this person is
desperate yeah it's easy to kill a
zombie they're mindless what about the
person begging you for help who you know
is in there and you're like you're gonna
get me sick and you that's a different
make them out that's what gets scary
yeah man having to deal with a bunch of
people running around just like
infecting everybody else mm-hmm so
what's the what's the what's the
likelihood this turns into what was that
game the division oh yeah yeah you guys
have you guys ever played the division
people who are watching it's uh
basically a plague wipes out the world
no just New York are you sure no no like
everything collapse right oh yeah maybe
I honestly don't remember exactly the
story but I do remember it was the
epicenter was New York and they
quarantined the island down so yeah and
then you but like they fight in the new
division you're like DC's gone that's
true yeah so it's like everything
collapsed yeah must have you know you
know what I tell people like whenever
comes to conspiracies or these big
stories like come on man you know life
isn't that there's nothing exciting yeah
those are movies life is boring yeah you
know I did I wake up poor cup of coffee
I come down I complain about Democrats I
said that B word that's what I do I
complain about politics to be fair it's
not bragging on myself it's boring you
know I mean like nothing happens you
know nobody really knows what's going on
for the most part this thing's not gonna
be
deal I know a lot of people there's so
many videos on YouTube where people want
to act like this is seriously the
apocalypse yeah and I'm like yeah maybe
but like look I don't have an optimism
bias and they say that for SARS too
didn't they say that for whine flu bird
flu nothing happens
you